[Music]
[Applause]
mr. president mr. Provost madam
secretary
Dean's college heads college Dean's
colleagues friends families and most of
all members of the class of 2019 welcome
to this day and congratulations I now
call on the University chaplain good
morning please join me in the spirit of
Prayer Almighty and loving God you are
the one who gives us this day in all our
days in the majesty of this life moment
we your beloved children of different
colors Creed's generations stories and
tongues are gathered in this place as
one human family United in jubilant
celebration we are filled with gratitude
for our families friends teachers and
guides their arms have sheltered us
their shoulders have boosted us and
today their hearts soar for us eternal
God it is you who calls us to our full
humanity as we celebrate our
accomplishments we are humbled and
overwhelmed by what lies ahead
steady us so that we may continue to
caress the beauty of your creation and
let our souls know true delights as we
awaken to the Wonder and mystery of our
own unfolding lives through the unity of
mind and spirit hold us ever close
as we seek to live in your world wisely
in the steadfast pursuit of your truth
and light for this we say Amen
oh that which pervades earth sky and
heaven which is worthy of worship that
has no beginning that which is the light
of wisdom and truth let us meditate on
the radiance of that divinity may that
brilliance help inspire and illuminate
our minds that one which represents
water lights and is the quintessence in
all things may that almighty spirit
pervading the earth atmosphere and
heaven bless us with enlightenment send
forth your lights and your truth they
will lead me they will bring me to your
holy mountain to your dwelling place
that I may come to the altar of God God
my delight my joy that I may praise you
with the harp Oh God
my god
you are the lights of the world a city
built on the hill cannot be hid no one
after lighting a lamp puts it under the
bushel baskets but on the lamp stead
where it gives light to all in the house
in the same way let your light shine
before all others so that they may see
your good works and give glory to your
God in heaven
God is the light of the heavens and
earth the likeness of his light is that
of an ish in which there's a lamp the
lamp is in a glass the glass is as it
were a brilliant star lit from a blessed
tree an olive tree neither of the East
nor of the West whose oil seems to glow
even though no fire has touched it light
upon light God guides whom He wills to
his light God makes parables for
humanity and God has knowledge of
everything
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
on this occasion it is customary for the
president to deliver a baccalaureate
address and for the Dean of Yale College
to offer readings my first of three to
you comes from my predecessor Jonathan
Holloway who four years ago greeted you
in this hall and welcomed you to Yale I
can't know if Dean Holloway foresaw that
you would be passing through Yale during
one of the most dynamic periods of its
history but in either case his words
were prescient here he is speaking to
you in 2015 the Yale you have just
joined looks radically different in ways
that would have been beyond the
imagination of the 18-year old men who
in 1965 sat in the same seats you occupy
today and the Yale of 2065 will be
something distinct from what your
present collective imagination can
summon this place is ever-evolving
and this is how it should be at a great
university you have come here at a
unique moment when this university
engages with questions of its own
identity you also bring your own
questions about your own identities and
what your future holds for you these big
questions will form part of the
education that awaits you but so will
the conversation that begins today as
you write your own story and build your
own Yale Dean Holloway supported much of
the story that you wrote and the Yale
that you built watching and admiration
as you worked to make this place more
inclusive to everyone
I have watched with my own admiration as
you have continued this work and with
gratitude for your engagement and for
your trust
throughout this period of change you
have shown resilience patience
confidence and love your commitment to
positive change was rooted in not just
your friends and men
but also in your ownselves my second
reading excerpted from CP kavafis 1911
poem Ithaca could have been written for
this day for you as you set out from
this place on the journeys you have
spent these past few years charting
similar to the commencement musical by
the Dramat called Pippin that president
Sullivan I had attended enjoyed last
Friday with our wives Parvati was
writing of Odysseus's journey home to
Ithaca but he could just as easily have
been speaking to you in words describing
the journey you have just completed or
the one ahead as you set out for ethica
hope your road is a long one full of
adventure full of discovery keep Ithaca
always in your mind
arriving there is what you're destined
for but don't hurry the journey at all
better if it lasts for years
so you're old by the time you reach the
island wealthy with all you've gained on
the way not expecting if Iike to make
you rich ethica gave you the marvelous
journey without her you wouldn't have
set out she has nothing left to give you
now and if you find her poor Ithaca
won't have fooled you wise as you will
have become so full of experience you'll
have understood by then what these if it
does mean my final traditional reading
comes from John Milton who famously
describes some young people you might
recognize and who like you found
themselves taking their first steps into
a new world beyond the one they knew and
loved I offer him to you now from his
Paradise Lost
some natural tears they dropped but
wiped them soon
the world was all before them where to
choose their place of rest and
Providence their guide
they hand-in-hand with wandering steps
and slow through Eden took their
solitary way congratulations class of
2019
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
graduates of the class of 2019 family
members and friends good morning it's a
privilege to be here with you today
commencement is a time of beginnings and
endings of looking to the future with
hope while saying farewell with both joy
and perhaps nostalgia it's a jumble of
emotions for all of us and a field day
for a psychologist enjoy all those
feelings it's hard to imagine you'll
ever have an experience quite like this
again so there's a wonderful Yale
tradition that I would like to honor
right now and so may I ask all of the
families and friends who are here today
to rise and recognize the outstanding
and graduating members of the class of
2019
[Applause]
and now I asked the class of 2019 to
consider all those who have supported
your arrival at this milestone and to
please rise and recognize them
[Applause]
thank you in September 1974 Kingman
Brewster then the president of Yale
spoke to the members of the class of
1978 seated right where you are
now he told them many of us have just
been on a ten-year trip of moral outrage
auntie Wallace anti-war an anti
Watergate
we have been so sure about what we were
against that we have almost forgotten
how difficult it is to know what we are
for and how to achieve it does this
sound familiar today perhaps more than
ever it is easy to know what you are
against and it's far more difficult to
say what you are for what we are against
is going to be different for each of us
maybe you're against border walls and
I'm against guns your neighbor is
against trade wars and your cousin is
against abortion for some capitalism is
the problem
while others fear the specter of
socialism by this point I bet all of you
are against sitting in an old building
with no air conditioning listening to a
long speech so I'll get to the point how
many of you have ever seen a Marx
Brothers movie right pretty good so
although I'm not mistaken for Groucho
Marx as often since I shaved my mustache
I I still do do have a weakness for his
humor and one of Groucho's best
performances of course is when he plays
a college president it is a funny role
so in the opening scene of the movie
horse feathers
Groucho the new president of Huxley
College is told that the trustees have a
few suggestions for him and he breaks
into song I don't know what they have to
say it makes no difference anyway
whatever it is I'm against it no matter
what it is or who commenced it I'm
against it your proposition may be good
but let's have one thing understood
whatever it is I'm against it I
encourage you to look up the scene on
YouTube not right now because it's still
a very funny piece and it's funny
because it's ridiculous but also because
it contains a kernel of truth and the
truth applies not only to college
presidents but to all of us how many
times have we decided we're against an
idea before we've even heard it how
guilty are we of deciding I'm against it
without even knowing what it is many
times we know what we're against based
on who's saying it if an idea comes from
a certain public figure politician or
media outlet we already we already know
how we feel partly this is because our
public discourse has become so
predictable
we've lost the capacity for surprise for
revelation speaking of predictable here
is the moment where an ambassador of an
older generation that would be me tells
Millennials most of you about the evils
of social media but hear me out
obviously social media has transformed
our lives and our relationships and
obviously it has many advantages
allowing us to share news and
information quickly with people around
the world
but it also heightens our sense of
outrage and speeds up arguments
depriving us of the time and space for
careful reflection bombarded with
notifications pressured to respond
before the media cycle turns over we tap
out our position our opposition in
seconds it's easy to be against
something in fewer than 280 characters
it's far more difficult to articulate
what you are for and to do it at warp
speed make no mistake there are plenty
of reasons to be outraged my generation
your generation we face not only grave
moral challenges but existential threats
rising ocean levels globally and rising
inequality in America violence around
the world and in our own backyards the
fraying of the social fabric the Falcon
cannot hear the falconer and we wonder
if the center can hold I understand the
impulse toward negativity like many of
you I sometimes feel overwhelmed by the
challenges we face by the injustice --is
that call out for our condemnation yet
it is precisely because our challenges
are so great that outrage is not enough
pointing out what is wrong is merely the
beginning not the end of our work the
Czech author
Yvonne clima wrote to destroy is easier
than to create and that is why so many
people are ready to demonstrate against
what they reject but what would they say
if one asked them what they wanted
instead what would you say
what would I say what are you for Klimas
life story is one of both criticism and
creation born in Prague in 1931 he was
sent to a Nazi concentration camp as a
child he survived and became an
outspoken voice for democracy in
Czechoslovakia but in 1968 with the
Soviet invasion and crackdown Klimas
ideas became dangerous he could have
fled but he chose to return home and
continue his work in defiance of the
communist regime he organized an
underground meeting of writers who
circulated manuscripts in secret over
the course of 18 years those writers
produced 300 different works of art they
were critics of course critics of
tyranny critics of violence but they
were creators - creators of plays novels
and poetry they imagined and helped
create a new and better world
what will you imagine a better business
a smarter school a stronger community
whatever you are against it is time to
create something you are for at Yale you
have learned to do both to imagine and
create you have studied and explored new
ideas made arts and music excelled in
athletics launched companies and served
your neighbors and the world you have
created a vibrant diverse and exciting
community take these experiences with
you and draw on them when you need
encouragement remember a class that
surprised you a conversation that
inspired you a professor
who believed in you and take care to
avoid what Toni Morrison calls
second-rate goals and secondhand ideas
our past is bleak our future dim
Morrison writes but if we see the world
as one long brutal game then we bump
into another mystery the mystery of
beauty of light of the canary that sings
on our skulls being for something is a
search for those mysteries for that
light it is an act of radical optimism a
belief that a more perfect world is
within reach and that we can help build
it what are you for you may well turn
that question back to me what are you
for
Peter Salome I'm for the transformative
power of a liberal education one that
asks you to think broadly question
everything and embrace the joy of
learning I'm for the American Dream in
all its rich promise
the idea that opportunities are shared
widely and that access to education is
within reach for the many not the few I
am further a bust and free exchange of
ideas as essential to the mission of a
great university as it is to the health
of our democracy I am for a world where
we welcome the immigrant the poor and
the Forgotten we do not shut them out or
silenced them a world where showing
empathy and understanding is considered
the true hallmark of success of a life
well-lived that is what I am for
yells mission says in part that we are
committed to improving the world today
and for future generations that
commitment does not end at graduation
soon
you will leave Yale and as Robert Penn
Warren who studied and taught at Yale
wrote you will go into the convulsion of
the world out of history and into
history indeed you will go into history
and make history looking around me today
I think of the generations of young
graduates who have come before you
individuals who have been for something
there are many names we know and others
that would be less familiar presidents
and world leaders artists and business
executives scholars and scientists like
them I know you will heed the call to
leadership and service and leave your
mark on every realm of human endeavor
that is yells mission that is what Yale
is for as members of the Yale community
what do we believe we believe that facts
and expertise applied with creativity
and wisdom can transform the world we
believe that education and research save
lives and make life more meaningful we
believe that diversity of thought and
diversity indeed are essential to human
progress we believe most of all in the
boundless potential of human ingenuity
that together we can solve great
challenges and bring light and truth to
a world in great need of it on Monday
tomorrow during your commencement
ceremonies I will confer on you
all the rights and responsibilities of a
Yale degree yours is a great
responsibility you will have to know
what you are for what are you for surely
in the light of history Eleanor
Roosevelt said it is more intelligent to
hope rather than to fear to try rather
than not to try Yale has prepared you as
a scholar and a human being to try to
face challenges with courage and
determination and I trust you are
leaving Yale with a sense of your own
responsibilities to one another to the
planet and to our shared future by
serving others and our communities with
the many gifts you have been given you
will live a life that is for something a
life of meaning and purpose there is no
time to waste there are no words to
waste as a young Bob Dylan sang in 1965
he not busy being born is busy dying we
must give life to new ideas imagine new
ways of being in the world new answers
to the problems that vex us and our
neighbors now is the time members of the
class of 2019 please rise
we are delighted to salute your
accomplishments and we are proud of your
achievements remember to give thanks for
all that has brought you to this day and
go forth from this place with grateful
hearts paying back the gifts you have
received here by using your minds your
voices and your hands to imagine and
create the new worlds you wish to see
what are you for congratulations class
of 2019
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
may God bless you and keep you may the
eternal show you favor and be gracious
to you may the Holy One cause light to
shine upon you and grant you peace and
let us say Amen
[Music]
you
[Music]